because of the facts the claims of medicine
the explanations a thousand dollars who
eat
and not for that reason
emery varied the way he can use
all those colors and bring his
character to life is something very beautiful
[Music]
manifested makeen's action always but
fundamental and  from new central hours
it started with facebook and nights
my word maskin coaching in the word i'm going to
save from arabic forums they must open
our hearts
[Music]
my name is maría pérez and i'm an artist i
started painting when i was
around 21 years old not only  not only did my plate fall
basically I have always
liked the day of the dead a lot so
when I saw his art it brought me ideas of things
that I could perhaps do with it
[Music]
if you look carefully at
the character indications the
technical scout pains  to eat and drink
whiting washington stories
collaborating with him as it has been a
way of expressing myself and seeing life
in another way
a more positive note
[Music]
berlin - dance better wo  rking more
deeply scanner of reflection age
derived from the arcane represented by
sectors of the writer frei march live
a
I love what is being done
because I think that if it is bringing that
celebration to many places where
perhaps people do not know those
Mexican traditions like that and  how beautiful they
are
also have been versions that
mark whitson my team and I don't
communicate authoritarianism in tucson internal
what we are trying to
do together expose more art something new
something that no one has seen before
[Music]